hello i will be giving a presentation
entitled treatment of co-occurring
methamphetamine and opioid use disorders
my name is mariah calman i am an
assistant research professor at the
department of family medicine at ucla my
background and training is in
epidemiology and i've been doing
research for the past 15 years
among
persons who inject drugs and persons
with hiv
in trying to understand effective
treatments for substance use disorders
have no disclosures no conflicts of
interest
for today there are three main learning
objectives first we will demonstrate an
understanding of the definition
epidemiology of methamphetamine use
disorder especially in the context of
opioid co-use
and we will describe the neurobiology
and development and maintenance of
methamphetamine use disorder and how
this relates to treatment outcomes and
then we'll review the evidence for
advancements in pharmacotherapies
and try to understand how that can be
translated into clinical practice
so in terms of epidemiology
this is the global picture of
methamphetamine use as of 2019 and it is
a global problem we see the highest
prevalence of methamphetamine use in
australia southeast asia
parts of northern and western europe
and the united states
in the u.s
the highest prevalence is observed in
california texas and a few other
southern states
now we know that overdose deaths
involving opioids have increased over
the last 20 years this slide shows that
overall sets involving stimulants has
also increased and what's important to
note is that
the
the rate at which
deaths involving stimulants
has increased just as much as the rate
at which deaths involving not involving
stimulants has increased we also see
the rate of deaths
involving synthetic
opioids such as fentanyl has increased
and these did it go through 2017 but
preliminary data from 2018 through 2020
also shows additional increases beyond
these
so in the u.s the general populate in
the general population the estimate of
methamphetamine use is relatively low
it's less than one percent but this
doesn't tell us the whole picture
there have been dramatic rises
of matthews among people who report
using heroin and lsd
and so
measuring methamphetamine used in the
general population
really
gives us an unclear picture of the
impact of methamphetamine use in the
substance using communities um likewise
the reuter article pictured in the lower
right
found that heroin use cannot really be
measured adequately using a general
population survey because it doesn't get
at
the
really vulnerable communities and how
they use heroin
and how they're at risk for overdose so
on the left side of the screen you'll
see that although over the last few
years the general estimate of
methamphetamine use has remained
consistent we see significant increases
among those using heroin and among those
reporting lsd use
and what this means clinically is that
there's been an increase in the
prevalence of acute heart failure among
those using stimulants because as they
use
more as we get more similar users as
they use more stimulants
we really see the effects of that
in terms of acute heart failure so we'll
see heart failure related to
cardiomyopathy we'll see heart failure
related to pulmonary arterial
hypertension
and although those
occurrences are relatively low in the
general population we're seeing close to
two percent in stimulant users which is
very high compared to what it is in the
general population
so now moving on to the neurobiology
first before we jump into that it's
important to understand the physical and
psychological effects of methamphetamine
and how they relate to the function
of specific subgroups who are
particularly vulnerable to using
methamphetamine
and suffering undue consequences from it
so as far as the physical effects we see
increased heart rate blood pressure
respiration energy
that corresponds to decreased sleep
decreased appetite
and
then and then in terms of the
psychological effects we see increased
confidence
increased sex drive increased energy
and decrease in boredom and loneliness
so these effects are directly related
to the subpopulations that
are known to use methamphetamine so
shift workers use methamphetamine
because they have to stay up at night
similarly
people who are unstably housed
often use methamphetamine at night to
stay up to stay safe
gay men use methamphetamine to increase
sex drive and increase uh
pleasurability during sex
and rural and youth communities often
use methamphetamine to alleviate boredom
and to experiment with a stimulant
so it's important to remember that
all behavior is brain
including
behaviors like using stimulants
so this is a motivated behavior because
it's motivated by physiological effects
and methamphetamine has direct effects
on neurons in stimulating sustained
dopamine release
and so behavioral and potential
medication therapies
affect neurotransmission and so we are
trying to target this neurotransmission
with these therapies in hopes that in
turn corresponds with behavioral
modification
so there's a cycle with
substance use and the brain and how the
brain
goes from one phase to the next in the
presence of substances
so
this figure describes that cycle and
what i really want to point out is the
far right side that's highlighted by the
red box and so
the brain cycles through various phases
depending on how substances are used but
it's really that far right side where
the brain is going through withdrawal
specific to methamphetamine we get this
profound dysphoria
and that is what we hope to target with
medications with behavioral therapies
you'll also see that this profound
dysphoria as it's repeated will lead to
neural adaptations the brain will
actually change
and that will in turn
change the response
the other responses and sort of instead
of going through this
pre-precipitated response
and the normal responsive drug will sort
of bypass that and go right into the
binge intoxication
so with stimulant use
um you do see this normal adaptation
that actually enhances the cycle
exacerbates it and
you know leads to the
ill behaviors that we see as a result of
methamphetamine use that's repeated over
time
so i mentioned earlier this profoundly
about dopamine so methamphetamine
inhibits dopamine reuptake and it
increases reverse transfer of dopamine
into the cleft so
what this means is that dopamine leaves
the brain
and it's inhibited in terms of returning
to the brain so you get this leaching of
dopamine
out of the brain and that's part of what
leads to this profound dysphoria
once
someone goes into methamphetamine
withdrawal
and there is a dose dependent effect so
low doses
of methamphetamine and amphetamines are
known to be therapeutic for some for
different disorders
and they simply block dopamine transport
but high doses
in addition to blocking transport also
reverse transport so it sort of
exacerbates that leaching of dopamine
out of the brain
so now moving on to pharmacotherapies
it's very important to know that
currently there is no approved
pharmacotherapy for any stimulants
including methamphetamine
there have been some promising primary
methamphetamine use disorder medications
there is mercazapine which is a known
antidepressant medication
that has been in the field for several
years now and has recently shown some
promise for treating methamphetamine use
disorder
there's also extended release naltrexone
plus high-dose bupropion which was
explored in the adapt ii trial
recently published
which also had a significant signal for
reducing methamphetamine use among those
with moderate to severe methamphetamine
use disorder
and there are significant factors that
increase the impact of these protocols
so first is that there's a lot of
research in among the poly substance
groups so
among those that use methamphetamine and
opioids together or
methamphetamine and other stimulants
together
we really don't understand
how
those drugs sort of interact and what
treatments might be most effective in
those groups
secondly these
some of these projects the
center-release naltrexone plus
propropion includes an injectable
product so this is the the long-acting
injectable
naltrexone
also known as vivitrol
and the injectable products are really
important because they eliminate
adherence issues so we've seen in other
studies
that
um
we that the
the effect of these drugs are lessened
when we they're relied to take every day
so the injectable products uh alleviate
that problem
so when looking at the merchandising
studies there's been two main studies
both have been done in a very similar
population in san francisco among men
who have sex with men
the one on the left was the first one
and we saw very a smaller trial of uh 30
individuals randomized to active
condition mertazapine 30 milligrams per
day
30 people randomized placebo and we do
see over the 12 weeks of that that trial
a steady decline in the percent of
individuals testing positive for
methamphetamine through urine drug
screening
and there was a very strong signal at
the end of 12 weeks
similarly
in a replication trial that was done the
figure on the right which was done in
the very same population indoor city san
francisco men who have sex with men
um we see a drop over 12 weeks and then
we also see a continued drop
over 24 weeks um same emergency and 30
milligrams a day
these are very important
findings because merchandising is a very
safe medication it's been approved as an
antidepressant and has anti-depressing
properties which is often a comorbid
condition of people with methamphetamine
news disorder
so these are very promising results
next
is the
extended release injectable naltrexone
plus high-dose bupropion this was the
adapt2 trial that was recently published
this was an adaptive trial so it had two
phases but the take-home point here is
that across the two phases there was an
11
difference um in methamphetamine use
among those who were randomized to the
naltrexone high-dose bupropion group
compared to placebo
so here instead of showing percent
positive urine sexually show percent
negative urines and you see a steady
increase
in the percentage of study participants
with methamphetamine negative urine drug
screens over the course of the study
and you see that both in the first phase
after the initial randomization and you
see that as well in the second phase
when non first stage non-responders are
then
re-randomized and have an opportunity to
receive the naltrexone bupropion
combination
you see those individuals also
experience a significant increase in
methamphetamine negative urines
we also see
a fair amount of positive outcomes
um beyond just
methamphetamine reduction
so
we also see a decrease in
methamphetamine craving very significant
decrease across both stages for those
who received the extended release
naltrexone plus bupropion combination
versus placebo we saw a decrease in
depressive symptoms as measured by the
phq-9 and we also see an increase in the
subjective effects of functioning as
measured by the treatment effective
treatment effectiveness assessment
so in summary there have been about 25
years of research in trying to find
effective medications for
methamphetamine use disorder and other
silent use disorders and there are still
no nothing that's fda approved
mertazapine has significant effects
in men who have sex with men which is
particularly impressive
and the effects are in reduction in use
not abstinence
but so far these effects are limited to
a relatively small patient population
and we really need more trials to
confirm that mertazapine can be used
for reducing methamphetamine use beyond
men who have sex with them
the adapt 2 trials very strong trials
with a strong signal for the extended
release of naltrexone plus high-dose
bupropion combination
but one thing to note about this
combination is that it cannot be used
among individuals using opioids because
the extended release naltrexone
would precipitate withdrawal
among anyone using opioids
and so we actually need an alternative
pharmacotherapy for individuals who are
co-using methamphetamine and opioids
now i would be remiss if i didn't
mention the other treatments that have
shown both efficacy and effectiveness in
reducing methamphetamine use among those
with methamphetamine use disorder
there's contingency management which
provides incentives for negative urine
drug screens for methamphetamine this is
actually the most efficacious and
effective treatment that we currently
have better than any medication or any
other behavioral therapy
motivational interviewing and cognitive
behavioral therapy have also shown
promise
there's the 12 steps approach which is
effective it provides patients with
structure and it provides them with
social support which is necessary as
they go through treatment
and lastly there's a harm reduction
approach
which
is effective in reducing mortality in
this in this patient population
so what that involves is methods to use
methamphetamine more safely so if you
have someone that's using
methamphetamine by injecting it
motivating them to use it either orally
or
smoke it
will
will result in
potentially reduced use reduced
frequency as well as reduced risk for
overdose and death
so
where do we go from here
and we really need to start to focus on
the
patients populations that use multiple
substances
either concurrently
or sequentially
use them together
to address the effects of of certain
drugs so here we have
individuals with methamphetamine use
disorder a portion of which use opioids
now they may have
opiate use disorder
but there's a substantial proportion
that probably don't have opiate use
disorder or at least they don't have a
severe enough opioid use disorder to
make them eligible for treatment for
that opioid use disorder now for
moderate opioid use disorder severe
opioid use disorder
those individuals would qualify for
medications such as methadone which is
the full opioid agonist or buprenorphine
which is a partial opioid agonist
those with
mild opioid use disorder or opioid
misuse would not qualify
for
buprenorphine or methadone
and so the next phase of research we're
really focusing
on this co-using population
now there will be an upcoming study
that's sponsored by nida through the
clinical trials network
and this study will be evaluating
injectable buprenorphine versus placebo
for participants with methamphetamine
use disorder and co-occurring opioid use
there may be prescribed opioids or
opioid misuse they may be either
misusing their prescribed opioids or
getting opioids from the street
or they might actually have mild opioid
use disorder so again it would not
qualify them for treatment
but it's still an issue for them they
still use opioids
in addition to their methamphetamine
so for these participants
we will be in uh screening them over 21
day period and looking for two positive
urine drug screens for methamphetamine
we will be looking for opioid use in at
least two out of the last 30 days and
we'll be looking for a negative urine
drug screen for buprenorphine methadone
and opioids on the day of randomization
because we don't want them
to have opioids in their system
at that time
just in case we would precipitate
withdrawal
there's about 250 participants in this
patient population
or in the study rather and they'll be
randomized in a one-to-one ratio
and then any participants
with um moderate to severe opioid use
disorder that are found during screening
will be referred to treatment for that
opioid use disorder so they'll be
referred to either a methadone clinic or
another alpha chain uh provider who can
prescribe them buprenorphine
and one thing to note
about the buprenorphine is that as i've
mentioned before it is a partial opioid
agonist but it's also a kappa antagonist
and that is why we think that it may be
useful for treatment of
methamphetamine use disorder because it
could potentially alleviate the
dysphoria
that's really prevalent and prominent
when
people who are using methamphetamine and
have severe methamphetamine disorder go
into withdrawal
and in fact there's been a few very
preliminary studies who've looked at if
you've been working for methamphetamine
use disorder and have seen a signal
there's been a small study two small
studies in iran
and then there have been some pragmatic
trials that have been using
buprenorphine for opioid use disorder
but have
found
in their secondary secondary analysis
that it also reduced methamphetamine use
for those individuals who were co-using
opioids and methamphetamines at the
start of the trial
so the objectives and outcomes of this
study are to evaluate whether assignment
to 12 weeks of outpatient injectable
buprenorphine compared to
12 weeks of injectable placebo
reduces methamphetamine use as measured
by twice weekly urine drug screens
during the last four weeks of the study
so weeks nine through twelve
and secondarily we are also going to
look to see if injectable buprenorphine
reduces alternate measures of
methamphetamine use
so self-reported self-reported use as
well as use over the whole 12 weeks as
well as measures of opioid use
and measures of methamphetamine and
opioid co-use and i just want to note
that
although we know that the
methamphetamine using population and
those with moderate and severe
methamphetamine use disorder do use
opioids we really have a lack of
understanding of the patterns of that
use there's very little data of an
understanding of how methamphetamine and
opioids are used together
although we have some anecdotal
information from providers and from
people using methamphetamine and opioids
there are no systematic assessments so
this will give us some clarity on that
and then we'll be also exploring some
other effects of methamphetamine and
opioid use in terms of pain and mood
instability and stress
infectious disease incidence and risk
measures of dysfunction and measures of
adverse events
so this study
is a double-blind placebo-controlled
trial so individuals randomize the
active condition will first get a
sublingual
buprenorphine film lead in
and then on day three they will get
injectable placebo 300 milligrams
compared to placebo who group who will
get a
placebo lead in and then they will get
an injectable buprenorphine
injection at day three and then they'll
get injections every four weeks after
that so at weeks five and nine
and then there will also be a follow-up
visit at week 16.
so in terms of translating
these results the results that we
already know and the results that we
will
hopefully the positive results that we
will hopefully see
into practice we have to understand
what that entails and
how to make these evidence
evidence-based treatments successful
in the real world setting and what we
need to make that happen is we need
inner energetic champions
in the field of substance use treatment
who
have
will raise an emphasis on translating
this these medications and these
practices
into their clinics they need to advocate
for investments in training staff and
changing workflows to make these
medications work
and they also have to emphasize the
whole person
so it's not just about the medication
but it's also about incorporating
behavioral therapies
using other people just besides
clinicians so maybe behavioral
specialists or peer recovery coaches
um
and
continued engagement with staff and
really understanding
how these medications can be used
effectively
there also needs to be a concentration
on infrastructure support so we need to
get since methamphetamine and opioids
both affect populations that are have a
high
degree of health disparities we need to
get these individuals
insured
connected to housing and employment
services
so one model that could
give us some
information and and an example of how to
structure our treatments for
methamphetamine use disorder is the
california bridge
i serve as the pi and project director
for the california bridge
which is a
[Music]
a clinical program that is
funded by samsa and other california
state dollars in the state opioid
response and is continuing to be
defunded by by
different different funding mechanisms
at the moment
and basically what it is is a direct
hospital
payment that goes to f to hiring a
substance use navigator the substance
use navigator serves as a liaison
between the patient and the provider so
as patients come in to emergency
departments
at these california hospitals
they are
right the substance use navigator is
trained to understand and recognize
potential signs and symptoms of opioid
use disorder and they can talk to the
patient about starting medication
particularly buprenorphine and then they
also engage with the patient understand
their barriers and challenges to
treatment and connect them to
other services housing employment and
then they follow up with that patient
that three days seven days and 30 days
to see that they're to to try to get
them to connected to outpatient care
if they return to the ed they engage
with them again at that point
and what we've seen is that this
approach for treatment of opioid use
disorder
by
interface by interfacing with patients
who are most severe and most dire and
have the least likelihood of
getting care in the outpatient setting
is very effective
so these data show that over the first
14 months of the study
the california bridge program across 52
hospitals identified over twelve
thousand patients with the opioid
disorder
administered buprenorphine to over seven
thousand of them
uh 5400 also received a prescription for
buprenorphine
and then about 4 800 actually reported
engagement in a outpatient visit with a
medication assistance treatment provider
at 30 days and so
to hit that mark of about 40 percent
we're engaged at 30 days is really
profound since this is a very vulnerable
high risk population
that goes to the ed for treatment but
also goes to the ed because they're
suffering from intense withdrawal
and they also have you know could have
go to the ed because they've had a prior
overdose
another aspect of the bridge is very
important is addressing disparities and
in this paper we looked to see whether
or not
the california bridge
patient population
um for those who are
particularly disadvantaged they have
medicaid insurance they report unstable
housing they report methamphetamine use
whether or not they receive hospitals or
buprenorphine or they receive a
prescription at discharge in the same
the same way that people without those
disparities and we found that the bridge
is actually doing a great job
and people who report unstable housing
are actually more likely than those who
are stably housed to receive hospital
administer buprenorphine during their eb
visit
those with medicaid and methamphetamine
use are equally as likely
as those with others insurance and
who
do not report methamphetamine news
respectively
and the same thing with um receiving a
buprenorphine prescription at discharge
those with medicaid are more likely to
get that prescription compared to those
with other insurance types and we see no
difference
in prescription
at discharge for those with unstable
housing or stable housing those
reporting methamphetamine use versus
those not reporting methamphetamine use
so in closing i'd like to say that
methamphetamine use disorder is linked
with the neural adaptation
of addiction and targets for treatment
and there's no broadly effective
approved medication for me for
methamphetamine use disorder but there
is some promise for mertazapine
as well as the extended release
naltrexone
plus high-dose bupropion combination and
hopefully we will see
some more evidence that buprenorphine
can also be effective in for reducing
methamphetamine use disorder and this
will be particularly important
in the
population that uses methamphetamine and
opioids together
and this raises the question as to
whether it's time for methamphetamine
use disorder treatment to start with
medication and as we see in the
california bridge
that model is particularly successful
because it uses buprenorphine as a
foundation and then also layers on
other interventions such as the use of a
substance use navigator
harm reduction motivational interviewing
to really foster that relationship
between patients and providers and get
them connected to outpatient care
and lastly integrated treatments provide
help to patients and these include
help that focuses on their biology their
behavior and their culture and these are
all important elements to helping people
reach and maintain goals regarding
reducing their methamphetamine use so
that we can minimize comorbidities
minimize overdose risk and ultimately
minimize mortality
i'd like to acknowledge uh several
people
first dr steve choptel who's my mentor
at ucla
provided
slides for this presentation as well as
the lead investigator of the clinical
trials network study that will be
assessing
the effectiveness of
injectable buprenorphine on reduction of
methamphetamine use
likewise my colleagues at the university
of texas southwestern who are also
working with us on that ctn trial
and my colleagues of the california
bridge the four directors
who are instrumental in
allowing us at ucla to lead some of
these research efforts
and implementing some of our proposals
i'd like to thank you for listening to
this presentation